Okay.
Today's discussion relies on three
bucks and one of them is high acts,
constitution of liberty,
which you've seen, uh, uh,
two chapters of online.
Another is Hernando de Soto's
mystery of capital. Uh,
and the third,
uh,
and by far most entertaining is our oven.
A Diego's the white tiger.
In today's class we're talking about
something really foundational and it is,
it is basically a pragmatic or
practical theory of freedom.
It's why is freedom of good thing.
And this is a much less high flown
theory than many philosophers would give
Hayak after all was an economist.
But it is a powerful one.
And for me it corresponds to
more or less to my convictions.
And the,
the most powerful aspect of it is that
I can profit from your freedom and you
can profit from mine.
Freedom is a common good individual.
Freedom is a common good in a
way that makes a great deal of,
of practical,
common sense to a lot of people,
including me.
We'll do it in four chunks.
We'll begin by looking
at high JAKKS framework.
Uh, we will then, uh,
take up briefly the question of government
and how government relates to this.
Then we will look at to Soto's,
uh,
the Soto's analysis of live and dead
capitol and his explanation of why
undeveloped countries remain
undeveloped in many cases. Uh,
and then finally we'll rub our
idea of freedom up against,
uh, the lives of the central
players in the white tiger.
And throughout this I'm
gonna, I'm gonna, uh,
advert, uh, from time
to time to a Yale story,
not the tragic one that is on the
front page of today's paper. Uh,
but an equally well now I wouldn't say
equal eight. Another troubling story,
which is the decision of Yale University
press when it agreed to publish a book
about the Danish cartoons,
which poked fun at the
Prophet Prophet Mohammed.
Uh, when that book was ready
for printing three months ago,
uh, the director of Yale University
press called me. He is, I'm on here.
I'm on the committee that decides what
books they publish. And the question was,
can we pull the cartoons out of the book?
These are cartoons which make
a devout Muslims very mad.
And the,
the answer we arrived at
very reluctantly was yes,
pull the cartoons and that point that,
think of that problem and think of what
possible explanation could there be.
Why a great university,
uh,
feels itself unwilling to stand
up for freedom of expression.
Uh, in the case of these, uh,
admittedly blast from us cartoons and, uh,
it turns out the answer is very practical
and I'll give you my position on it by
the end of class. Okay. Hi.
Eric was a charming guy and
a very practical thinker,
a less practical perhaps then
economist who worked for banks.
Uh, but, uh, as Nobel
laureates go very practical,
uh, he was, uh,
given to thinking about hard cases
about why things were done as they were.
And he was most of all
a n intellectual skeptic.
He was most of all inclined to doubt
human knowledge to lean on salability and
ignorance,
uh,
to look at Marxists.
Historicism which we discussed
last time as horse feathers.
He was contemptuous of,
of not,
not Mark's alone,
but of whom so ever imagines that there
is a deterministic course for world
history.
Hey and that they know what it is.
Be neither a nor B washes with high Eq
and the region it doesn't wash
is that he believes in freedom.
And in free societies,
outcomes are unpredictable.
We're going to read this
for a second for yourself.
It's the worst sin in the use of
PowerPoint is to put a lot of words on the
screen and then read them to people.
It makes me furious when I'm in
the audience and people do it.
So can you read it for yourself
in the back there? Hey,
and we'll parse it a little bit.
Civilization,
which no brain has designed,
but which has grown from the free
effort of millions of individuals.
Okay?
And
the idea here is this is a
very powerful idea. It is.
If you say, who designed the world
in which we live here at Yale,
how long would the list be?
Or let's try this. Let's take the highest
ranking officials of Yale University.
Um, let's say, uh, Roland batch,
who is the chairman of the Yale
Corporation, uh, and Rick Levin,
who is the president of the university.
And let's throw in Linda Lorimer,
who's the secretary
and Mary Miller,
who's the dean of the college,
and think of four or five
others that might be important.
What percentage of what goes on
around here? Did they think up?
Take a guess who we have a mic out there.
Just hand it to the
woman right behind her.
Let's get her guess what percentage of
what percentage of the way we do things
at Yale is attributable to the five
highest ranking officers? The University?
5%.
You think that much?
Let's pass the mic around to
what I can tell. You've got
something to say. Go with it.
Yeah,
it doesn't seem to be on.
Okay. Third repetition. The question is,
take the five highest ranking
officers of the university.
Take everything that goes on around Gail.
What percentage of it can we
attribute to them thinking it up?
I'd say way less than one. And I think
they would say way less than one.
Right.
And it's because the university has
been invented a piece at a time over the
centuries.
It's reinvented every day.
What you do in the classroom
is part of reinventing. Yeah.
What you do elsewhere is part of it.
And the notion of a free society that
Hayak wants to put in front of us is one
queer agency.
The right to make decisions
is widely dispersed.
And you can imagine, you can
imagine societies in which
that isn't true. In fact,
many exist,
uh,
one would be an authoritarian society
and autocracy where a ruling elite pretty
much says what happens.
Another would be traditional
society or a sus,
a theocratic society where
there are standing rules,
they are more or less followed and
they restrict agency in a sharp way.
A new haven colony in the years,
1637 to 1665 was a strict theocracy
and the rules were laid down in the Bible.
A solum scripture from was
the idea they made no laws.
All they did was interpret the
Bible and enforce it harshly.
Uh, Hayak has in mind something
very different from that.
And
the,
the idea that society is in some sense
a great learning machine or that a free
society is a great learning
machine is the powerful idea,
uh, in high x work. If we think of,
you know,
I'm given to these extravagant charts,
historical time on this dimension
measured let's say in centuries,
uh, or in human generations if you
prefer. And on the vertical access,
the total shared store of knowledge that
that society accumulates knowledge as
trivial as how to manufacture a toothbrush
or as complex as how to operate a
great university.
The accumulation of that knowledge is
high acts as accelerated exponentially by
dispersed agency by freedom
and the rate of accumulation grows in an
exponential curve with a free society.
Uh,
he doesn't talk about demography,
but I would say that a free society
which has passed through the world
demographic transition so
that people live long lives,
lives in which a great deal of
learning can go on after decade,
that such a society embedded in the
institutions of a free society would have
the sharpest upward upward curve in
the accumulation of shared knowledge.
The other side of that story, and here
I've added a second axis on the right,
which represents the percentage
of a society's knowledge,
which one very competent
person can capture,
right? Who's the most competent?
Rick Levin is very competent,
never brilliant, always thoroughly
competent. It's really true.
I mean, it really is true. I mean,
part of why he's so good is he
never tries to be brilliant.
He never ever heard him say
anything that was even vaguely edgy.
I've known him 40 years. We used to
ride home together at night whenever.
He's never anywhere near the edge,
but he's never,
never, never crazy. He's
just, he's the most thorough.
He Bright. It's the personality
profile for an airline pilot,
a heart surgeon,
and maybe the president of a university.
Uh, so it's, it's a very steady,
very competent persona.
And high x,
big point is that no individual,
however competent can know any major
fraction of what of the knowledge
accumulated in a free society over time.
And that,
first of all, it's humbling, right?
It's terrifically humbling.
And part of what the sort of education
all of you are getting is about learning
what you don't know and learning where
to find out the things you don't know,
which through time you need to know.
But it,
it,
it is not imagined that this or any
other college can create graduates who
master any large fraction of what is
known in the United States or the Western
world,
much less the world at large.
So as knowledge accelerate,
the individual fraction of that
knowledge becomes smaller and smaller and
individuals become more and more dependent
on things discovered and known by
others.
Take the toothbrush.
Who's got a mic here?
Let's go to the gentleman
in the red tee shirt.
Uh,
if it were
your assigned in your first job
to set up a manufacturing plant for
ordinary plastic toothbrushes with nylon
bristles,
how would you go about it?
Okay. That, that incidentally is
where this photograph came from.
Case to go to Wikipedia.
You think Wikipedia has got a design for
a toothbrush factory now maybe when you,
okay, what'd you'd begin doing
is reaching out to others. Right.
And you would probably have to
reach out to several others.
Uh, and those others, the others who
actually make these toothbrushes are,
do you think that youth, suppose those
plants are located in New Jersey?
Um,
not really sure.
I'm pretty sure,
Mike,
I don't even know this,
but I'd be willing to offer a
substantial bet that the vast majority of
toothbrushes are manufactured somewhere
in Asia or the southern hemisphere,
probably Asia.
Uh,
and I would also bet that no one in this,
does anyone in this room have a
clue how you'd go actually about it.
Okay.
Injection molded plastic,
right? No one knows.
And yet each of us,
each of us profit in a small way from
tens and hundreds of thousands of bits of
knowledge like that.
I got said,
examine this chart now. I think maybe
if we work cooperatively in the room,
we could learn what it's about.
I have no idea.
I certainly can't read these labels.
There's anyone here who can read them.
Okay,
cool. Go get, let's get her. Let's
get her a mic so we don't miss this.
Okay.
MMM,
mmm.
Okay. Re-Export. Right.
This is a history of a British,
uh,
British exports,
ena complex bar chart and the fact that
are there other people who knew how to
do it and didn't, didn't
raise her hands. Okay.
What we see here, this is kind of
a division of Labor story, right?
It's a little like Adam Smith and the
pin factory that we rely on others as
store houses of knowledge, uh,
useful to us or at least imaginably.
So in my example,
um,
this is the model t Ford and it was
produced for the first time in numbers
between 1910 and 1917 and it was a
revolutionary machine by 1917.
It was,
well, when it began, it was selling
for about a thousand dollars,
which would be a lot more than
a thousand dollars today. Uh,
by 1917,
uh,
the Ford Motor Company had figured out
how to make this car and make money on it
by retailing it for $360.
And they had done that by combining,
uh,
many pieces,
many small pieces of
engineering from other fields.
And by using a moving conveyor belt,
which carried the car along and workers
who stayed in position each with an
assigned task,
each coordinated in a very efficient way.
And the larger implication of that,
uh,
for the American and world economy,
the knowledge embodied in it was
enormous and it was wholly unoriginal.
Ford was not a brilliant engineer.
Some of the people he hired were damn
good engineers by and large though they
were just regular smart people who
worked in a cooperative team way,
a division of labor about ideas.
And there was a,
an older idea called the American system.
And the American system was,
uh, interchangeable parts.
It was parts made so precisely identical
that you could take the left front
wheel drama off one model t and put it
on any other model t and expect it to
fit. And that idea, which,
and that's actually one of the
revolutionary ideas that's involved in the
vertical vertical spike of world
affluence and which has been,
uh,
dispersed everywhere in the globe.
You can't manufacture anything
in a competitive way if
you don't understand and
execute on interchangeable
parts. The earliest, uh,
alleged case was actually new haven.
It was that you like Whitney gun factory,
the waterfall on Whitney Avenue,
the little building there.
Eli Whitney had a contract with a federal
to make 10,000 muskets and he set out
to do it with interchangeable parts.
And what's fascinating
is if you go out there,
they've got a couple hundred
of these things in the drawers.
He knew he got most of
them just a little wrong,
so he would file them or his workers would
file them and Chevy them to make them
interchangeable. But from the
point of view of the military,
the idea of interchangeability was
huge because when one part of a weapon
jammed,
you could take another
one and interchange it.
And the efficiency of the
logistics were enormously improved.
But the military is mainly
what that idea is about.
Okay.
Anybody have a clue who this is?
Fair enough. There's no
reason you should. Um,
this is the Guy Norman Borlaug.
Correct.
Uh,
who did the critical work
on developing high growth,
high bro Productivity,
disease resistance, seeds. Uh,
most of the work done 50 or 60
years ago. He died last week, uh,
which increased agricultural yields,
yields on a world basis,
uh, so that there is still hunger
in the world, but it's all manmade.
That is,
there are no cases in the world now
where there isn't enough food to feed
everybody. There's always enough food, uh,
if it doesn't get to the right places,
that's something to do with
human agency or institutions.
And all of us benefit from that work.
And that work in turn benefited from
generation after generation of botany and
husbandry.
Uh,
and all this process of building the
social store of knowledge is what high x
idea of freedom is about.
And this is Dean Mary Miller and by
now I've beaten this horse to death.
Uh, she's wonderful.
She's absolutely terrific.
But what fraction of the curriculum
she supervisors would she need to have
direct knowledge of
if she knows what we do in here,
she wouldn't. She'd only know if I were
in a lot of trouble or you work. Um,
there are hundreds of courses,
even thousands and the
dispersion of agency,
right?
The last summer I sat at my summer house
in northern Vermont with a stack of
books about that high,
picking the books for this course.
She didn't supervise that.
Uh,
neither would I have
been pleased if she hand,
but the effect if she,
if she has the right people doing it
and trust them is very like Adam Smith's
pin factory and the division of
labor and the power it produces.
So we're back to Smith.
Smith had the idea that by dividing
labor so that one person doesn't,
doesn't, uh, undertake the whole
complex task of manufacturing a pimp.
If you divide the labor among many who
get good at specific aspects of the task,
you can make it cheaper and more efficient
than otherwise it would have been
high acts id is more loose
jointed than that. Hi.
Acts idea is that you don't
even assign roles to people.
You let them find their own roles.
Okay.
That if you want to go out and start
a toothbrush factory using a novel
technology
invented late,
late at night over beer
with your roommate,
what's the likely outcome?
The likely outcome is that you will fail.
Your toothbrush will be too
expensive and not very good, right?
Isn't that the likely thing?
And,
and if you think about a market economy
as literally hundreds of thousands of
people who make decisions like that,
go no,
go with a new model toothbrush,
the accumulated knowledge from
that is enormously powerful.
And if you begin to make money
with your new model toothbrush,
then a couple of things will happen.
One capital will flow toward you.
People will say,
we would like to own part of this and
our subject next Monday is a joint stock
corporation,
which is all about that.
So capital will flow towards you.
And so we'll competition.
As soon as you begin to succeed,
people will attempt at to get as close
to your product as the patent and
copyright laws permit and to compete
with you on the basis of quality or price
and that process,
you can think of it as an
enormous diversified portfolio.
The whole economy,
no one directs the whole economy or says
where the capital goes though sometimes
it feels as if Goldman Sachs
comes close to that. The,
the decision process is
highly decentralized and
unprogrammed and indeed Hayak
if you'll look closely says,
well let's find it.
He says that what we're trying to
do is create the opportunity for the
unexpected to happen.
Liberty is essential in order to
leave room for the unforeseeable,
an unpredicted.
We want it because we have learned
to expect from it the opportunity of
realizing many of our aims
so that uh,
so that
the core idea is dispersed.
Power of action.
No,
hi is
entirely dependent on the idea
that we are limited intellect.
If we were,
as this quote says,
Omniscience the page 29,
the green quote here up there would
not be so strong a case for freedom.
I think there would be other cases,
but the core case that Hayak is making
is that freedom is a way of overcoming
our own fallibility and of allowing
others to fill the holes in our individual
stores of knowledge.
Okay.
Now, high tech, early in
the section you read, uh,
focuses on the question or rock climber.
It's kind of a jarring reference when
when you see it, it's at the very,
I think it's about around page 12.
Yeah.
Um,
I read most people will still have enough
feeling for the original meaning of
the word free to see that if you know,
sorry.
Uh,
in this sense,
freedom or first solely the relation
of men to other men or persons to other
persons or the Omi infringement of it,
of it is coercion by men.
This means in particular that the range
of physical possibilities for which a
person from which a person can choose at
a given moment has no direct relevance
to freedom.
The Rock climber on a difficult pitch,
who she's only one way out to save
his life is unquestionably free.
Most people will still have enough feeling
for the original meaning of the word
free to see that if the same rock climber
were to fall into a crevasse and were
unable to get out, he would only
figuratively be called unfree.
Now that's,
that's a big,
there's a lot rides on that claim
and high act offensive unevenly.
If you look closely at the
way he defines coercion,
you'll find that the rock climber
story is the clear and easy case.
And the end of our slides today,
we'll,
we'll begin to look at some harder cases
and some of those hard cases are raised
by the white tiger book.
Now
this is more my kind of rock
climber hanging on barely.
I'm terrified of any height
greater than five feet.
What's behind the story?
What hi accusing isn't sneaky here.
Anybody want to tell us
why he makes this argument?
Because he is arguing in an environment
where communism is a very live option.
And the Marxists position about freedom
is that it's a bourgeois delusion.
And that only by giving
everyone the same access to,
to material rewards,
to money,
wealth and the like,
only by downward redistribution of money,
wealth and the like can real
freedom be shared by everyone.
Okay.
And Hayak wants desperately
to head off that argument.
Now whether that argument
is right or wrong,
uh, is actually more
semantic than anything else.
And we'll actually close with a
slide about this. That is to say,
can you be free?
And at the bottom of society,
unable to do many, many things,
unable to effectively rec,
uh, effectively exercise your freedom.
One view is that the two dimensions,
freedom and uh,
wealth or power are entirely independent.
Another view is that without
some degree of market power,
some degree of ability to interest others
in your needs through exchanging your
skills and your labor for what it is
that you need or for the money which will
buy what it is that you need or want
only with some degree of market power,
uh, can freedom be fully realized.
And I'm of that second view,
I am of the view that the wide dispersion
of relative affluence is part of
making freedom real.
And the way I would argue that with
Hayak is that conceptually the concept of
coercion is,
is extraordinarily slippery.
Let's consider the guy in the crevasse.
He stuck.
But you and I are walking by on our way
to a picnic and he calls to us and we
say, sorry, we're late to the picnic.
Yeah.
Uh,
it would be not it,
you wouldn't have to much twist the
language to say that that was an implicit
act of coercion on our
part. Okay. And then,
then the slope gets dangerous and complex.
Uh,
if he had diabetes and we withheld
from him the treatment for diabetes,
would that violate his freedom?
All I want you to do,
what I really want you to do is get the
power of high x idea in your head and
get the complexity of applying
it in your heads. Now,
the reason I think some
degree of affluence or some
degree of market power is
part of the deal is that high
acts examples all depend on it.
The things which he,
which he tells us about in the second
chapter are all ones where people have
enough education,
enough physical health,
enough skills that they
can be real players.
No.
Now the, uh, d good questions
and this is a degus social
class we're seeing in this slide
are different. Okay, let me, we're
going to go to dig in a few minutes,
but let's pause and talk
about the Danish cartoons,
which I'm not going to show
you. Um, you can see them.
All you gotta do is Google them.
Um,
and they are from an Islamic point
of view blast from us and they are,
um,
from a western secular point of
view there in some ways. Funny. Um,
this cartoon which is a
cartoon about cartoons,
captures the idea that the scriptural
blast from the seen by the Muslim here is
on the same plane with the secular
blasphemy seen by the advocate of free
speech. John Bolton is a Yale
alum. I even know him a little.
He was bushes representative
to the UN and he's a,
an a,
um,
radical libertarian and he's on the
war path against Yale over are not
publishing the cartoons.
Let's stop and talk practice for a minute.
We got, Yup. Pick somebody out.
Okay.
Okay. Uh, can you
imagine any circumstance?
The few, the proud, the
Moose. I like it. Um,
can you imagine any circumstance under
which you would say that we should tell
the university press?
Not to publish the cartoons in the book.
The book will be out in about a week,
but without the cartoons.
Okay. You went, you cut straight
to the chase. Very well done. Uh,
the point just made is that the
university consulted experts
and the question to the experts was,
what's the probability of a terrorist
attack launched against Yale,
uh, in response to the
publication of the cartoons.
Okay.
And the answer came back that
it was not insubstantial.
Now
why would that be?
Would you,
um,
you got to grab it and talk to it.
Would you be inclined to take
the libertarian possession
and say Yale was the
kind of place which stands
up for freedom of expression?
Yeah,
I think you could make the case that
yields stands up for freedom of expression
of a lot of cases,
but not all.
Okay. And so let's, let's see.
Can we have, we got a sh a
true gospel libertarian in the room.
We've got somebody who wants to say
damage. You should have published them. I,
I don't mind being criticized.
Yeah. Yes, we need to, yeah.
If you'll come forward a little,
it's going to make it easier.
Yes.
Darwin,
Darwin Day were the pictures of fish
eat on that walk when we went to the
landmines.
And I think that the best approach would
have been probably to try to create an
academic exchange whereby
every university, uh,
to slip the cartoons in
some public place because
you're the kind of guy,
Rick Levin. Thanks. No,
that was good.
The Richard.
Okay.
Um,
if the argument is that the
right to life is going to
raise possible chances of a terrorist
attack bowls going to be and it's a
slippery slope and the minute you
get into this sort of, um, uh,
appeasement before is that
intention threads down the road,
the potential that you're giving up
multiple or a societal amount of freedoms
to,
to appease and aggressor if you own,
you're actually bringing that up
and even greater existential, right.
I agree that that would be
one of the counters and it,
and it is a persuasive one.
It's important.
The issue here
gets to be,
it comes down in my view to the
effective ability to defend,
uh, the institution. And when I
say defendant, I mean defendant.
And the next topic for us if I've
got these slides organized right,
is the nation state system.
And what we have here is a quote is a
question of narrow gauge state failure.
The Guy Pictured is Thomas Hobbs.
His great book,
the Leviathan came out at the same time
as the settlement to the 30 years' war,
more or less.
And they were two faces of the same thing.
Hobbs central idea of the Leviathan was
a power so great and so well disciplined
that it could monopolize force and
violence in society and keep people from
attacking one another and put down a
general set of rules of law which allowed
people to know what was coming next.
And if the Leviathan
we're fully effective,
I would favor publishing the cartoons
and my reasoning would be similar to the
reasoning.
A back left that uh,
freedom is freedom and
freedom includes bad taste.
I think blasphemy is very bad
taste toward any religion.
It's bad taste,
but the fact that I deem at bad taste
doesn't make it make it inappropriate and
inappropriate exercise of freedom
for those who take a different view.
That's the whole idea of freedom.
Now,
what's missing here
is that in some fundamental way,
uh,
the al Qaeda events work,
they did in some degree work.
We all pay rent on them every
time we fly, right? If there,
I mean,
think about the person hours
consumed taking shoes on and off
and the perfectly good bottles of water
or shaving cream which are confiscated,
uh,
the critical aspect of state performance,
the rule of law reliably and forced
zones of freedom. For example,
within our own property
here at the university, uh,
corruption minimized and the monopoly
on force and violence effective.
Now,
what nine 11 was about was an attack
on our culture and a demonstration that
even the mightiest nation in the world,
uh,
NATO mightiest nation in
the history of the world
was open to violent attack,
especially if you are willing
to die in the process.
And we have been convinced by that.
And if you,
if you actually think about
defending the Yale campus
against it,
just imagine a single person,
uh,
willing to die or spend his life in
prison for attacking Yale in the most
spectacular possible way.
What would we have to do to the campus
to rule that out called the new haven
police department?
You must be kidding,
right?
I mean they don't have anything like the
resources to do it and our own police
force doesn't come close
to being able to do it. Uh,
the campus is built on the premise
that the monopoly on force and violence
works. It is built to deal
with petty criminals, right?
The locking of gates
in that kind of thing.
But the locking of gauges entirely
useless against a terrorist and arid.
I soberly thought about this and I thought
I would much rather take the ringing
first amendment point of view,
but uh,
and I was only one of many
people involved in this judgment,
but ultimately,
uh,
I couldn't bring myself to undertake
that risk on behalf of all of you.
And uh,
Richard Postelli is correct
that that represents a,
a loss of something. And a
step on a slippery slope.
I think that's really true.
Uh, but it's real. And, uh,
the virtue of high x way of thinking
is that it's not all or nothing.
It is a pragmatic judgment about
how best organized society.
Now Hernando de Soto,
third topic,
mystery of capital,
it's a middle middle difficulty books
that very difficult and it's all built on
one point.
And the one point is the distinction
between formal and informal property.
The photo I showed you before
is a favela near Rio in Brazil.
Uh,
and it's all informal property.
The people who built those
houses don't really own them.
They own them according to
a set of informal rules that
operate among the people
in the favela.
They don't have formal
documentation for them.
So it is informal property.
Every building in new
haven is formal property.
Even community gardens
are formal property.
There is a deed written down, you can
trace it and you can show it to a bank.
And
desotos major idea is
that informal property
is dead Capitol
and formal property where the power of
the State stands behind your ownership is
live capital.
And his claim is that poor people in
developing societies own a vast amount of
capital in informal forms.
Yeah.
And that just as capital is formed in
advanced market societies by combining
many small assets into
smaller number of big assets.
So to Ken,
capital B,
four in poor countries by formalizing
property and allowing people to make
investments by taking on debt,
which is secured by formal property.
And his further claim is that many of
the worst economies in the world are the
worst economies in the world because the
number of hurdles to form that stand in
front of you when you want to formalize
your property are wildly excessive.
I'm going to do the white tiger at
the beginning of class next time.
I urge you at one of you came up
to me at lunch today and said,
wow, this is fun. I mean, it is.
It is one of the great novels of this
era and I promise you if you'll just give
it an hour,
you're going to love it and we'll start
with a white tiger on Monday and then
we'll go to the joint stock corporation.
The reading for Monday is on the web.
Now in Classes v two,
it's the Alfred Chandler
piece about railroads.
You will need to go to Ras. Uh,
when we get to the Harvard cases,
there are three Harvard cases.